- If it has a penis
it's probably about sex.
- It's when someone
texts you late at night
and they say, "You up?" cause
they looking for the goods.
- What are the goods?
- The sex goods.
- They want to sleep with you
but not in the conventional
(snores loud) sleep.
More like the (imitates creaking noises).
- Look, I have never sent one of these
because I'm a gentleman. (laughs)
(imitates creaking noises)
- It's a squeaky door?
You guys ever received,
or sent 'you up' texts?
- I plead the fifth.
- I think so, yeah.
There's some, there's a couple times,
where I've left a bar...
- I normally send those
I don't receive those.
- Nah, I've never said, "You up?"
- Sometimes the nights get
cold, the nights get lonely.
- Uhh...
- You got to check to see
if you're wife is up because
(laughs) if she's awake
then you might be able
to watch TV with her.
- If you get a 'you up'
text the dude's just like...
One he's not creative.
- I might have sent a 'you up' text
once or twice in my life.
- How about you just ask
them about their day.
How about you ask about
how things are going on...
- Did it work?
- Um, no.
- Can I get an Amen?!
What are we doing up in here?
Stop sending 'you up' texts.
Stop sending them.
We got to do better people.
- Oh, I always do y-o-u
because I keep it classy.
- You have to spell it you in any context.
- I don't associate with people
who only use the letter u.
- Just u. Got to keep it real.
- I do put in yo because I
like to keep it informal.
Keep it hip.
- If you get a text late at
night, it says, "You up?"
It means somebody want to get them goods.
And them goods be all the
good things you have to offer.
I'm not going to impose
how you have sex upon you.
Maybe a door, maybe a bed.
- Thank you, yeah. Great.
- But nothing else.